seven years ago
when you first started diving seven
years ago i watched the video with you
swimming and with the you know with the
with the
the mermaid thing on your legs
and you did three laps under the water
right you went back and forth underwater
three laps yes this is my first
150 meters seven years ago
seven years ago how long could you keep
your breath underwater
not today but seven years ago uh
two and a half minutes so you went from
two and a half minutes to 24 minutes
that's right you uh you have to
understand
uh seven years ago i was a
smoker as well i did the three packs
of marlboro sorry for say
the name of the cigarette uh three packs
a cigarette a day and one day one day
i asked my coach am i going to be a
better
because i'm not competing just to
compete
i want to compete to be the best if you
want to be
if you and i we can compete
how long you will uh keep your mouth
shut
and i will win i will try to him if you
know what i mean
for me everything is a competing i mean
not in a
in a in a bad way if you know whatever
sure
i i i want to i want to compete
if i lose i lose if i win i suppose
i i'm going to win what is your birthday
i know you said you're 56 but when
you're
15 okay it's got it
interesting and you're super competitive
so you're smoking three packs of
cigarettes a day
yeah i asked you michael say to me my
coach said to me
okay if you stop smoking now
for the first year you will have a worse
result than now
do you know why because of co2
cigarettes makes you
to uh make co2 easier
because you are smoking you are making
that kind of
uh poison in yourself already okay
but when you stop smoking
your kind of your your amount of oxygen
you'll take much higher than now
and i said to myself okay what's my
vision
uh when i was a kid i was trying to do
something special
to go to die with some
respectable result in any area
could be a cooking could be sport
could be uh amount of girls that i have
been if you know what i mean and now we
come to
the point that i am the guy at this
moment with
56 years old and no one can beat me at
this moment
well don't i have to be modest but
at this at this point try if you can
try to beat me because i have more space
than you know because i'm doing like
bubka
i was ready for 28 minutes
in season i was ready for 28 minutes my
goal
is half an hour which i know that
it's impossible for 99.9
free divers in the world i don't know
how it happens
but it happens first of all i train
seven days a week never stop i have no
time for rest because i'm 56 if you know
what i mean
when you are 20 you you you have uh
schedule two days of training one day
rest two days of training one day's
rest now when i when you're 56
you don't have a time tell me why right
why do you not have time
because you are 56 in two years time
but but training wise my body
will never accept this
two years from now if you know what i
mean it will be much
harder it uh it would be a
many kind of disease i could have in two
years if you don't know what i mean
with my eyes with my blood pressure with
my uh
with lots and lots of lots of things so
i don't have
too much time in front of me maybe two
years
in a competitive way to be
one of the three or four the best free
divers in the world
and that's my goal in two years time
what i did
that would be that would be top and i
will say okay
i gave you homework it's a half an hour
see you in a 30 or 40 years and you will
still
[Laughter]
so if you like this sort of shortcut
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye